tous
[Musique]
quand je dévoile une partie de mes
origines
la réaction est bien souvent ah ben
c'est fou on ne dirait pas en effet avec
ma peau bien blanches et mes cheveux pas
trop foncée on ne soupçonne pas à
première vue qu'en plus d'être suisse je
viens aussi du costa rica
c'est dans ce beau pays d'amérique
latine que j'ai passé une grande partie
des études mon enfance en plus d'adorer
la chaleur tropicale
les longues plages sans fin la nature
flamboyante
ce que j'aime plus que tout c'était
surtout la chaleur et la proximité dans
les relations avec les membres de ma
famille se blottir les uns contre les
autres dans le canapé du salon ou sur le
lit de mes grands-parents se faire des
massages en regardant la télé toujours
une accolade sympathique pour se saluer
les années ont passé
j'ai continué ma vie en suisse fait mes
études commencé à travailler et petit à
petit comme beaucoup de gens
ma vie a été envahi par les écrans
aujourd'hui dès que j'ai trente secondes
de libre je consulte mon téléphone
portable je fais pratiquement plus
aucune réunion au travail son ordinateur
je passe une grande partie de mes
soirées à regarder des séries à la télé
et avant d'aller au lit je prends ma
liseuse avec moi il manque plus que la
montre connecté pour pouvoir consulter
mes sms encore plus rapidement on
connaît jamais on a passé autant de
temps interagir avec des objets plutôt
que directement avec des personnes en
france en 2018 un adulte passé en
moyenne cinq heures devant un écran par
jour une augmentation de plus de deux
heures en dix ans et ce chiffre monte
jusqu'à neuf heures par jour chez les
adolescents aux états unis et un adulte
consulte intéressent à moi sa journée en
moyenne 200 fois pour consulter son
téléphone portable
on connaît encore mal les répercussions
de ces changements sociétaux rapide sur
la santé et le bien-être
mais s'il ya quelque chose que la
science se connaît depuis maintenant
longtemps c'est qu'un facteur primordial
pour la santé et le bien-être
ce sont les relations avoir à 7
personnes sur lesquels on peut compter
et cruciale non seulement pour se sentir
heureux et épanoui mais aussi très
concrètement pour la santé physique
en effet des décennies de recherches ont
démontré que se sentir seuls et isolés
et autant mauvais pour la santé que de
fumer ou que d'être obèse et vivre
seules augmentent de 30% le risque de
mortalité
quand j'ai commencé mon doctorat ya plus
de dix ans j'ai intégré un projet qui
cherchait à comprendre comment les
partenaires de couple s'influencent
mutuellement au jour le jour dans leur
humeur c'était l'occasion idéale de
mieux comprendre comment les relations
en cet effet positif si puissant dans ce
projet nous avons demandé aux
partenaires d'indiquer plusieurs fois
par jour comment il avait interagit l'un
avec l'autre et que les telles rumeurs
on pouvait ainsi investiguer quels types
d'interactions sont les plus bénéfiques
pour l'humeur j'ai commencé par explorer
les facteurs bien connu dans la
recherche montrer de l'empathie apporter
de l'aide concrète ou alors aussi
communiquer de manière positive
mais rapidement un facteur auquel je ne
m'attendais pas et ressorti du lot le
toucher intriguée j'ai voulu connaître
d'autres travaux scientifiques sur le
sujet mais surprise les chercheurs ne
semble s être que très peu intéressés au
toucher et encore moins à ses effets sur
le bien-être avec mes collègues je me
suis donc mise au travail pour affiner
mes analyses tout comme les embrassades
massage et câlins qui au costa rica me
rendait si heureuse quand j'étais enfant
j'ai découvert que cantat partenaires
touche l'autre
l'humeur de celui ci s'améliore quasi
systématiquement dans les heures qui
suivent donc recevoir du toucher rend
heureux en plus la personne qui donne le
toucher
à bénéficie elle aussi avec une
amélioration de son humeur donc que l'on
donne ou que l'on reçoive le toucher le
bénéfice est le même nous avons aussi
trouvé que les coups pieds se touche
plus fréquemment au quotidien en retire
des bénéfices à long terme on peut
observer une amélioration générale de
leur bien-être dans les six mois qui
suivent
depuis d'autres travaux scientifiques
ont confirmé les bienfaits du toucher on
sait aujourd'hui qu'ils sont qu'il est
bénéfique pour la santé physique qu'ils
influencent positivement plein de
facteurs de physiologiques de bien-être
qu'il améliore les relations qu'on a
avec les personnes qu'on touche et
qu'ils aident aussi à gérer les conflits
pourtant tout le monde peut en témoigner
il est bien des situations où le toucher
n'ai pas vécu comme agréable et encore
moins comme bénéfique
je sais pas vous mais moi j'ai pas mal
de peine avec les poignées de mains qui
sont trop molle ou trop forte ou alors à
me retrouver série contre des inconnus
dans un bus et combien d'enfants en font
la grimace quand on leur demande de
faire des bisous à d'autres personnes
donc clairement on peut quand même pas
s'attendre à ce que tout le monde soit
tout le temps content qu'on les touche
n'importe où et dans n'importe quelle de
n'importe quelle manière dans des
travaux plus récents
j'ai cherché à savoir qu'est ce qui va
faire que quelques fois le tout chez
nous compte de joie et d'autres fois ils
nous dérange voir nous rebute
dans une étude
nous avons demandé à des participants de
venir en couple dans notre laboratoire
et nous les avons soumis à une situation
stressante
nous leur avons demandé de faire un
exercice où il y avait de très grand
risque de se tromper et nous avons
mesuré le stress avant et après
l'exercice
les participants ont été séparés en
trois groupes
groupe a ils faisaient l'exercice seul
sans aucun contact avec d'autres
personnes
groupe b ils faisaient l'exercice en
étant touchés sur l'épaule mais par une
personne inconnue
groupe c ils faisaient l'exercice en
étant touchés aussi sur l'épaule mais
par leurs partenaires
malgré toutes les erreurs que les
personnes ont commises durant cet
exercice difficile
les personnes qui avaient été touchés
par leurs partenaires se sentait moins
frustré à la fin de l'exercice que
celles qui n'avaient pas été touchés par
contre celle qui avait été touché par
une personne inconnue n'avait aucune
différence avec celle qui n'avait pas eu
de contact physique
d'autres études scientifiques ont aussi
montré que le toucher du partenaire a un
impact réel sur la réactivité au stress
le toucher d'une personne en qui on a
confiance nous aident à gérer le stress
avec plus de sérénité en résumé pour que
le toucher soit bénéfique il est
nécessaire de connaître et de se sentir
en confiance avec la personne qui nous
touche en ce qui concerne la personne
touchée
eh bien on sait qu'il ya des gens qui
sont plus ou moins fan de câlins on
connaît tous au moins une personne qui
affirme haut et fort ne pas aimer les
caresses et autres et fusions ou en tout
cas pas comme ça où dans cette situation
ou à ce moment là les scientifiques
nomme les personnes qui n'apprécient pas
l'intimité qui répugne de parler de
leurs sentiments pour les autres et qui
préfère ne compter que sur elle même
salle ayant un style d'attachement
évitant la recherche a montré que ces
personnes aiment bien moins le touché
que les autres et qu'elles préfèrent
l'éviter
j'ai donc voulu savoir si pour ces
personnes avec un style d'attachement
évitant le toucher serait moins
bénéfique que pour les autres et à ma
surprise
non nous avons trouvé que dans un couple
le toucher est associé à autant de
bénéfices pour les personnes qui
n'apprécient pas l'intimité que pour
celles qui le font
en bref même les personnes les plus
réticentes face aux touches et bénéficie
de celui ci quand il est échangé avec
leurs partenaires de couple une personne
de confiance et on peut faire
l'hypothèse que ce partenaire quand il
touche l'autre il a une attention
positive de lui faire du bien
donc ceci m'a poussé à continuer mon
enquête sur le toucher en investiguant
les intentions qui se cache derrière on
peut toucher pour amadouer manipuler
séduire ou alors se blottir pour ne pas
déprimer ou pour éviter un conflit
toutes ces motivations nous les avons
classés dans les motivations dites
négatives ou d'évitement les motivations
positive elles sont celles qui vise
intentionnellement le bien-être soit le
sien comme on peut toucher pour se
sentir mieux ou plus joyeux ou alors le
bien-être du partenaire comme toucher
pour lui montrer qu'on est là et pour ou
alors lui faire plaisir
nous avons trouvé que les jours où les
bains partenaires touche l'autre avec
une motivation positive la qualité
relationnelle de 6,2 personne est
améliorée par contre les jours ou au les
personnes se touche avec des motivations
d'évitement comme la peur d'un conflit
la qualité relationnelle des deux
personnes est diminuée en d'autres mots
les intentions derrière le toucher
change son effet il peut être positif si
on le fait en visant le bien-être mais
aussi négatifs
si on le fait pour éviter des problèmes
après avoir investigué la qualité du
toucher je me suis demandé quelle
quantité de toucher pouvait être la plus
optimale si touché son partenaire est
bénéfique
est-ce qu'on devrait alors essayé de se
coller le plus souvent possible à son
partenaire imaginez ça deviendrait vite
infernal donc dans une enquête réalisée
en suisse allemand nous avons trouvé que
plus les personnes échangent du toucher
avec leurs partenaires plus leur
satisfaction de vie est élevé jusqu'à un
certain seuil
mais à partir de ce seuil les personnes
qui se touchent vraiment beaucoup
les fèves a dû toucher va diminuer
être moins positif donc comment ça se
fait eh bien on peut s'imaginer qu'on
arrive à un point de saturation où on
peut aussi faire l'hypothèse que les
personnes qui se touchent vraiment
beaucoup le font pour des motivations
plus négative comme avoir un grand
besoin d'être rassuré ou alors une envie
de contrôler le partenaire donc cette
étude montre que le toucher est bon il
est nécessaire de le faire fréquemment
mais qu'il faut quand même pas exagérer
l'importance de l'équilibré avec des
moments d'autonomie et de distance mais
en effet cette étude montre quand même
que pour être bénéfique le toucher doit
être pratiquée régulièrement et le
toucher c'est aussi les caresses et elle
stimule le désir et vous et moi savons
très bien que dans un couple il en faut
parfois peu pour passer de quelques
caresses à plus si entente est ce que
alors les coupes qui se touchent plus
souvent ils seraient plus heureux
uniquement parce qu'ils se font plus
souvent l'amour
en effet on sait que les gens qui ont du
sexe plus fréquemment on a bien être
plus élevé est-ce que ça serait alors la
seule explication des bienfaits du
toucher et bien dans une série d'études
nous avons montré qu une raison
importante qui fait que le sexe est
bénéfique et rend heureux c'est qu'il
permet aux partenaires d'échangé par les
caresses plus d'affection le toucher ren
ai donc fait donc partie intégrante des
bénéfices de la sexualité
en résumé le sexe rend heureux parce
qu'il permet aux partenaires d'être
d'échangés a touché emprunt d'affection
voilà je vous ai présenté plusieurs
études qu'est ce qu'on peut retenir de
tout ceci
on a vu que le toucher est bon quand il
est échangé avec une personne de
confiance quand même les personnes les
plus réticentes face au toucher et la
proximité bénéficient de celui ci quand
ils échangent avec leur partenaire que
c'est quand le toucher est fait avec des
intentions positives qu'il déploie tous
ses bénéfices que il est important de
toucher son partenaire fréquemment mais
qu'il faut quand même pas exagérer et
enfin que le touch et affectueux fait
partie intégrante d'une sexualité
heureuse dans toute cette mosaïque de
résultats quel est donc le facteur qui
va faire la différence entre un touché
qui est bénéfique et un autre qui ne
l'est pas et bien ce qui va faire la
différence c'est le message que le
toucher transporte est l'ingrédient qui
va faire que le toucher va passer de
dérangeant voire désagréable à
bienfaisant voir exaltant et bien c'est
ce qu'on appelle dans le langage commun
l'amour c'est comme toucher est là pour
donner recevoir partage et de l'amour
qu'il déploie tous ses bénéfices pour la
personne qui le reçoit et pour la
personne qui le donne alors la prochaine
fois que vous serez devant vos écrans en
train de s'écrouler en ligne pour
trouver la dernière recette de bien-être
le gadget qui changera votre vie
l'accessoire ultime qui vous sublimera
regardez vos mains vous avez au bout de
vos doigts la possibilité de donner
gratuitement et magiquement du bonheur
de la relaxation de la confiance à ceux
que vous aimez
et cerise sur le gâteau plus vous en
donner plus vous en bénéficiez vous même
alors ne vous en privez pas merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]